i could either do do sort of do a phd
and watch the internet happen or i could
participate and help build it in some
fashion
i like to have one at least one really
big challenge a year
that kind of centers me and and keeps me
honest
we can ultimately build a much larger
company by entering into those new
product categories
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
life hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
top lessons from billionaire
entrepreneurs enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one expect success with elon musk
and generally you want to
embark on something it's desirable to
figure out if success
is at least one of the possibilities
right exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes
um but but ideally you want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah
um and i wasn't quite sure if that was
the case um
i mean i think success on an academic
level would have been
quite likely because you can publish
some useless paper and
uh most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect
i'm sorry i mean have how many phd
papers are actually used
by someone ever um i mean no it's a good
point percentage-wise it's not
it's not good yeah uh and um
so so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
you add some leaves to the tree of
knowledge
yeah okay um and then that leaf is nope
it's not possible
right they go seven years a month
so that so that was one path and i was
prepared to do that but then the
internet was
the error came along and i was like okay
the internet i'm pretty sure
success is one of the possible outcomes
and it seems like i could either
do do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen
or i could participate and help build in
some fashion you know
put you know like i just couldn't stand
the idea of watching it happen
yeah yeah so that that's uh so i decided
to put things on hold
uh and start an internet company
and that was kind of a we we worked on
internet uh like publishing software
maps and directions yellow pages kind of
things
lesson number two understand the
customer with bill gates
how would you define your strengths and
your weaknesses how you can
you know incorporate those into a team
kind of aspect well i'm not
somebody who knows a lot about marketing
you know i wouldn't enjoy being a
salesman
for a position where you're actually
creating the products and thinking
through what those features should be
i'm fascinated by that i've followed the
history
of the industry read about the mistakes
that have been made
so product definition product creation
very strong
if you have a team that understands the
customers the sales the marketing i'm
not gonna bring that but i
i would enjoy working with them lesson
number three diversify with jeff bezos
the question was um why uh why did we
expand into things like electronics
tools and kitchen
since those businesses are not today
profitable
um and the answer is that um
that it increases our adjustable market
size so
we can ultimately build a much larger
company by entering into those new
product categories
and and second while it's true that
those
new categories which are only three
years old and by the way electronics
tools and kitchen is now
a 600 million dollar business at
amazon.com which makes it
one of the largest on and it's on a
standalone basis it's probably in the
top
four or five e-commerce companies
anywhere in the world
um so that business is growing and
growing very rapidly
and has it one of the big advantages has
a huge audience of early adopters which
is why companies like segway choose us
as the exclusive launch platform for
products like that because
really early adopters are the kind of
people who buy stuff like this
so it's uh but that business ultimately
will be electronics in particular in my
opinion will be our largest
most profitable business one day when
you start a new business
there are certain fixed costs that come
along with starting that business and
then the business has to reach enough
scale
so that the profit from the business the
variable profit
can cover those fixed costs there's no
sidestepping that and it's just a simple
investment
issue lesson number four be obsessed
with grant cardone
i hear a lot of guys saying right now
like hey only do the things you want to
do
dude i do stuff i don't want to do every
single
day okay so i don't know who these
people are that
don't do the things they don't want to
do maybe they were given a business or
something but
i'm going to tell you something man if
you don't do the things you don't want
to do you're not going to grow your
business you won't keep your business
i'm telling you
you have to be willing to do you got to
be so obsessed that you don't
care see an obsessed person doesn't care
if they have to clean a toilet
uh-huh you know an obsessed person
doesn't care if they
if they don't like that activity but
they have to do it you're obsessed
you're in it you do it anyway
no matter what i remember my mom told me
one day she's like you know
grant i love you just the way you are
because i tell i'm telling her about all
these dreams i have as a child right
yeah and i was reminded when my sister
told me like 30 years later
you know grant you've done a lot we love
you just the way you are and i'm like
dude i wonder how many times i've been
told that
you know and and the fact is so what
they love me just the way i
am i don't i don't
love me just the way i am which opens up
to this whole field of people that's
like
just love yourself the way you are look
if you're broke
you're not living on purpose you don't
like your job you can't get away from
your job dude
if you're stuck in a house you don't
like why would you want to love that
you should become obsessed with hating
it man it's obsessed or average one of
the two
so pick just pick get a t-shirt obsessed
or get another t-shirt average which one
would you be more proud wearing right
yeah who do i want to be man who do i
want to be how do i
how do i want to die man i want to die
all in
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five don't
waste money with mark cuban we gave it a
good go
right from 01 to 08 we trusted it back
up but it was
they they did slip on a big banana peel
purple and yellow banana peel for yahoo
for you that know their colors
that was another thing wait now so we
we sell to them right and our office is
in dallas
and the way we ran our business it was
just like lean and mean right
you invest in your product you invest in
your customers you invest in your people
and you know we had open offices you
don't need fancy stuff
they immediately came down and just
redid
all the furniture in purple and gold i'm
like it's cool that's my
high school's colors you know but why
are we spending this money got a whole
new office a whole new building
you know i'm just like why are we
spending this money one of the things in
my rules right when i look at companies
to invest in
if someone walks in with swag here's my
coffee mug with my logo
here's your t-shirt with my logo i don't
see anybody wearing a t-shirt with a
startups logo do you
no would you wear some other startups
logo polo shirt
hell no hell no right
it's just a waste of money you know put
your money where you're able to
differentiate yourself
and add value that separates yourself so
you can get ahead
don't waste it lesson number six use
your disadvantages to succeed with larry
ellison
can you take me back and tell me how
you've done this larry you're
you're the godfather of technology you
founded this company you're still
thriving
you're still coming with all these
innovation things and i could see
how passionate you are you're beating
everybody um
and you came from such humble beginnings
grew up on the south side of chicago
dropped out of college now you have
collections of cars
jets private homes owning the island of
of lanai
tell me how you did it well i think i
think my favorite line is i had all the
disadvantages necessary for success
you know uh when you're raised on the
south side of chicago
you probably want to move someplace
nicer and
i think if it doesn't kill you and makes
you stronger so
i've always been very ambitious i've
always been very curious
uh i would you know
moved to silicon valley right out of
right after i dropped out of college
and got a job as a computer program i
learned how to program when i was in
college
and i got a job as a computer programmer
and uh bummed around
yosemite valley teaching rock climbing
and and
um and leading river river river trips
uh during my early twenties but um the
way i supported myself was a
computer programmer uh and i got
involved with more and more
interesting and complicated uh computer
projects and decided to start my own
company
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is focus with jesse itzler i thought a
monastery would just be all prayer
reflection meditation
and a meal a day or something but a huge
part of it is manual labor
because they have to keep the lights on
and the monastery that i went
to uh which was not it was not buddhist
it was russian orthodox they were the
largest breeders of german shepherds
in this country and i remember the first
day i was
my job the first day was to be a
distractor so they were training one of
the dogs and i had to like run in front
of the dog and
you know try to like get them off of his
game to simulate
traffic in the city or distractions and
the goal is to have the dog be able to
walk unblemished no matter what you
throw at him and i was going crazy i was
running at him i was like you know doing
the far trick
all that stuff and um the dog
didn't waver it just walked from point a
to point b
and uh one of the monks that was
training the dog said to me it's no
different than life
you know it's like giving me all this
like you know wax on wax off
but he was saying you know you're gonna
get distracted from your goals
and all these things arrows are gonna
come at you all the time
but the same way this dog goes from
point a to point b even if there's a
pork chop there
whatever your goal is you got to get the
point you have to get there
even though people are going to say you
can't do it even though people are going
to throw
different opportunities you know you
know i'm sure your friends went out a
million times to happy hour when you
were to stay late
when you were starting your business i
mean i was in the same situation
those are the distractions that come at
you but to get to your goal you can't go
to happy hour every night
you have to return emails and you have
to check the manufacturer and you have
to
check the inventory and you have to make
sales calls how in your life have you
stayed the course how have you
stayed focused when you had and maybe
this goes to your why
you know what was it that allowed you to
keep going when your friends were going
out to happy hour
well i think like everybody i feel
overwhelmed a lot still
even though i'm older now and i've had
some success
and failure but i still have a lot of
arrows that come
at me all the time requests for my time
challenges at work challenges raising
kids being in a marriage
you know is not easy i mean we have a
great marriage but it's not ease work
sure um and it's overwhelming so for me
i think part of it is always having
something
big on my calendar that i can look
forward to uh
every mo every other month um
i try to put something on my calendar
for a weekend that i can really look
forward to so it helps me get through
the tough times
and i like to have one at least one
really big challenge a year
that kind of centers me and and keeps me
honest
it keeps me honest and that's really
helpful
for me and then the other thing that i
do that really helps is
i have a journal and i just take
everything that's on my
head and i keep it in a master journal
doesn't mean i'm going to get to it
doesn't mean it goes away
but it gets out of my head and it goes
somewhere else
to free up space in my head and then
i'll just work it off or i'll prioritize
it from the master list but just the
act of taking all the stuff that's in
your head
putting it on paper in one place where
it lives
is like really freeing and energizing
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35 percent to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan
publicly that jumps to 95 chance of
following through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you one of the things when i really sit
and think why
why am i comfortable taking risks what
is it yeah
um where i come from i was really lucky
when i was growing up my dad
used to actually encourage my brother
and me to fail
and so i would come home and sit at the
dinner table and he would say
sarah what did you fail at this week and
if i didn't have something he would
actually be disappointed
and i can vividly remember coming home
and saying dad dad i tried out for this
and i was
horrible and he would high-five me and
what i i didn't realize so awesome i
didn't realize it at the time but it was
he was teaching us that failure is is
not trying versus the outcome
and so with spanx and everyone's saying
it was such a bad idea initially and
you know i feel like i i feel much freer
to be willing to
you know fail in the traditional sense
because i'm not focused on the
end result and the more it's like
working a muscle the more you're willing
to
risk something and maybe fail you
realize there's always a really awesome
hidden gift in it
you know it's either you meet someone
new that brings you to a different place
in your life or you learn something new
or
and and so i always was really excited
by
what how my life grew by every risk i
took
[Music]
if you want seven more awesome lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i find if i don't
get enough sleep then i'm i'm quite
grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
are that way
and and also like i try to sort of
figure out what's the right amount of
sleep